mais d'abord les arbitrages avant de
soumettre au parlement le paquet pouvoir
d'achat que prépare le gouvernement que
proposent les oppositions premiers
éléments de réponse avec mathias ares
paquet pouvoir d'achat du gouvernement
la nuque présenté mardi son propre texte
pour répondre à l'urgence sociale
familles ne savent plus comment elles
vont pouvoir aller travailler quand
total notamment mais pas que distribue
des milliards de dividendes taxer les
dividendes de quoi dégager des marges de
manoeuvre et financer une série de
mesures comme le smic à 1500 euros ou
une garantie d'autonomie de 1100 euros
pour les plus précaires le texte veut
aussi autoriser un blocage des prix par
décret encadrer les loyers ou encore
instaurer une première tranche gratuite
de consommation d'énergie pour les
ménages va travailler par un moment moi
la question que je pose au gouvernement
et c'est une question qui est de fond et
qui est une question qui va conditionner
aussi la manière dont nous allons
travailler sur les cinq années qui vont
venir c'est kate vous prêt à accepter de
notre parti l'exécutif qui doit
présenter jeudi un paquet de mesures
chiffrées à 25 milliards d'euros ce
matin elisabeth bornes et plusieurs
ministres étaient réunis à l'elysée pour
plancher sur le sujet parmi les mesures
attendues un shack alimentaire un
bouclier tarifaire sur l'énergie ou
encore une remise de 18 centimes par
litre de carburant
c'est une indemnisation qui concernerait
tous ceux qui travaillent tous ceux qui
sont obligés de prendre leur voiture
pour aller travailler est évidemment en
fonction du niveau de revenu le prix à
la pompe c'est aussi la priorité des
républicains ils ont envoyé leurs
propositions pour le pouvoir d'achat
elisabeth bornes plutôt qu'une aide
financière pour faire le plein les as
l'air réclament une baisse des taxes en
france on est les champions du
matraquage fiscal et après on fait des
chèques
fait l'aumône de quelques chèques ale
quelques catégories avec des règles
totalement incompréhensible qui en
général exclut toujours les classes
moyennes première préoccupation des
français le pouvoir d'achat est en tout
cas au centre des tractations au
parlement avec une bataille
d'amendements en perspective sur le
projet de loi du gouvernement voilà
reportage signé fabien rey caire
évidemment je vous présente mes invités
pour ce tout premier débat anne charrier
de bezina bonsoir bienvenue le
constitutionnaliste maître de
conférences en droit public et millsap
elle skie bonsoir merci à vous aussi
communicante fondatrice de l'agencé
mini-conseil mathieu sous caire dans
soir mathieu bienvenus essayiste auteur
de 2022 la flambée populiste ses co
écrit avec damien fleurot essai publié
chez plon et lætitia cuba et l'italien
sceptiques bonsoir laetitia on démarre
donc sur ce thème du pouvoir d'achat il
ya un double enjeu le plus important
d'avancer pour les français les les plus
précaires pour ceux des classes moyennes
aussi qui font des fins des sacrifices
et puis and sharing bezina il ya aussi
l'enjeu du nouvel équilibre politique
c'est celui qu'on va le plus commenté
ici et là c'est intéressant street est à
la fois la stratégie du gouvernement et
des oppositions comment vont-ils se
positionner là dans les prochaines 48
heures en effet la première chose qu'on
a eu à l'esprit c'est se dire un texte
sur le pouvoir d'achat pour commencer
c'est une bonne chose puisque le pouvoir
d'achat est quelque chose qui va
apparaître unanime à partir du moment où
on parle de social on a le sentiment
d'offrir des cadeaux aux français ça
passera mieux or pourtant on se rend
compte que de droite de gauche du milieu
on n'a pas du tout la même conception du
pouvoir d'achat et des aides qu'on peut
y apporter donc on commence déjà un
petit peu mal sur ce premier texte
notamment avec cette force de
contre-proposition qui utilisent
l'opposition au lieu d'amender le texte
alors bon je suis heureuse d'entendre de
la voie de la nuque est justement ils
entendent passer par la voie de la
demande mais on a aussi quand même par
exemple le groupe henner qui envoient
des propositions donc c'est au parlement
surtout ça doit pas se faire par des
propositions de loi il faut amender le
texte existant pour proposer des
modifications sur l'existant pour que
l'ensemble soit cohérent si on fait des
contre-propositions loi on perd beaucoup
de temps on sait en plus que les
propositions de loi de l'opposition
n'ont absolument aucune chance d'aboutir
donc on perd du temps on est vraiment
dans l'obstruction parlementaire pour
être utile ça va être compliqué quand
même de se mettre d'accord aussi sur un
certain projet social surtout avec un
groupe du ps qui est important puisque
on est aussi dans un contexte il faut
pas l'oublier ou l'économie souffre
beaucoup et où donc il va falloir
finalement bruno le maire l'avait dit
notamment avaient joué un petit peu le
la reconduction de son ministère sur
cette question-là la fin du mois qu'il
en coûtait la fin de ce qu'il appelait
l'argent magique donc le discours de
réalité va devoir être martelé celui
aussi du pouvoir d'achat mérite
évidemment des négociations mais c'est
sur ce test là qu'on va voir comment
majorité et opposition dans savoir
travaillant soir fois aussi ce sera un
bon test est mis en place qui c est
intéressant c'est que les les deux
enjeux dont je parlais celui réelle du
pouvoir d'achat et de ce que les fruits
d'un savoir comme comme conséquence
communauté et puis celui du jeu
politique ils sont en miroir c'est à
dire que les stratégies des politiques
elles se construisent pour frapper
l'opinion pour ne pas décevoir l'opinion
c'est ça qui est tout à fait y avait
quand même avant le pouvoir d'achat il
ya une petite tentative sur l'île
égéenne pour inscrire sa dans
l'institution en écho à ce qui se passe
aux etats unis et puis vu que rapidement
ça n'a pas fait consensus même au niveau
de la majorité en tous cas par la voix
de françois bayrou on sent que ça a été
un petit peu mais sous la piste et une
proposition de loi de rares berger si je
me souviens bien mais on voit bien en
effet que là les enjeux sont clairement
politique et pourtant ça répond à une
des préoccupations principales des
français est une réalité de la situation
économique et sociale des français à
l'heure actuelle mais moi je trouve que
c'est intéressant alors évidemment
chacun prend position là on est juste
avant le match on est en train de se
montrer les muscles avant de rentrer
dans le match vraiment dans l'arène
parce que chacun essaie de garder sa
position d'opposant majeur alors la
nuque c'est évidemment qui fait un tir
groupé quand même proposition de loi
c'est la deuxième fois que ce qu'ils
sont en tir groupé aussi sur la motion
de censure
et puis aussi les républicains qui
auraient pu jouer un petit peu plus
l'alliance avec le gouvernement et qui
pas du tout dit a maintenant nous on
veut pas de chèque et on l'a entendu par
olivier marne ex donc ils cherchent à
vraiment se différencier avoir une
proposition autres moi je trouve que
c'est pas inintéressant parce que vous
parlez projet de société c'est là qu'on
peut commencer à discuter en disant est
ce qu'on met des mesures en effet qu'ils
sont temporaires des dispositifs est-ce
qu'on ait quelque chose de plus pérenne
c'est une occasion rêvée pour lannux de
remettre en avant et vous l'avez dit
vous me disiez on a on a le programme
encore de lannux c'est pas le programme
de la nuque c'est le programme de jean
luc mélenchon c'est le programme du
candidat à la présidentielle de jean luc
mélenchon il sait c'est une espèce de
rampe de lancement oui mais je suis
assez d'accord pardon après on sait que
si on est programme contre programme on
n'est pas dans l'air du temps qu'on
n'est pas dans la construction
parlementaire
c'est un des mages moi je la pense que
c'est un démarrage c'est ce que les
français ont demandé qui est des
discussions alors au parlement il sait
que les prêts discussions c'est les
préliminaires avant qu'on passe vraiment
aux discussions optimum parler vraiment
de la forme notamment par amendement est
plutôt par proposition ou là je trouve
que le moment où ils ont eu un
gouvernement qui pendant un quinquennat
a n'a pas accepté la plupart des
amendements oui donc c'est une façon un
petit peu de faire de faire la nique et
de dire ben voilà on va pas on va pas
faire comme vous nous avez refusé de
faire pendant cinq ans sauf que ça ne
nous a pas échappé la commenter à de
nombreuses reprises la situation elle a
légèrement changé mathieu soupière avec
cette situation de la majorité
relative mais je rebondis serait ce que
vous dites sur la stratégie pour
l'instant commune de la lgv ou p2 la
nuque qui annonce une motion de censure
tous les partis de là nous pouvons y
partiront alors été on est des jeux déjà
enfin le premier message c'est non on
n'est pas là pour construire voyez ce
que je veux dire oui mais tout ça
rappelle précisément que la politique
c'est du clivage en vérité le cléac'h
est de retour évidemment on rêve tous
enfin on rêve tous en tout cas une
majorité de français rêvent d'une
politique qui se construirait deux
façons différentes de façon beaucoup
plus apaisé de façon moins clivante en
réalité il y à des clivages et aux
législatives encore une fois les
français ont pas voté pour une majorité
relative il se trouve que le rapport de
force a abouti le rapport de force dans
l'opinion a abouti à ce que il y est une
majorité relative mais en été vous avez
des gens qui ont voté pour la france
insoumise les gens qui ont voté pour
l'extrême droite des gens qui ont voté
pour macro et donc à la fin ça fait un
jeu d'équilibré différents et et la
nouveauté c'est ça c'est non seulement
la majorité relative on en parle
beaucoup mais au delà de la majorité
relative le fait nouveau c'est l'entrée
au parlement de force d'opposition
radicale où on a les deux en même temps
t on à la majorité relative et on a une
à gauche radicale qui étaient déjà
présentes très présente dans les débats
parlementaires mais beaucoup plus
nombreuses et on a par ailleurs
l'extrême droite fait nouveau qui est là
et qui va investir le champ
parlementaire alors qu' il y a dans
l'adn dans le corpus idéologique de
l'extrême droite l'anti parlementarisme
là on voit que pour la première fois
dans notre histoire des plus récentes et
même plus longue l'extrême droite va
devoir jouer un rôle parlementaires et
de ce point de vue là ce dont on causait
sur la question du pouvoir d'achat est
assez révélateur effectivement le
pouvoir d'achat c'est la question la
plus consensuelle du monde c'est pas une
préoccupation parmi d'autres c'est la
préoccupation écrasante largement
écrasante depuis des mois et des mois on
l'a vu pendant la présidentielle ça
perdure évidemment avec le contexte
global donc c'est la question la moins
clivante du monde et pourtant pour
aborder la question la plus consensuelle
et le moins de clientes du monde voit
bien que tout le monde n'a pas du tout
les mêmes réponses qui finance en fait
les gains de pouvoir d'achat est ce que
c'est le salarié lui-même en faisant
comme le propose par exemple groupe ait
l'air une 1 rachat de ce2 de ces de ses
rtt non je je je je menais arize
valorise jeu moneim rtt ou est-ce que
c'est précisément une augmentation de
salaire imposée à l'ensemble des
entreprises comme le propose la france
insoumise évidemment que les réponses ne
sont pas les mêmes à des crises
semblables mais vous l avez dit en
préambule de votre prise de parole c'est
le clivage politique c'est à dire que
c'est une politique de droite versus une
politique de gauche il me semble qu
emmanuel macron gouvernent à droite ce
que je voulais dire là c'est que ça
illustre cette passe d'armes avant même
le débat parlementaire avant même que le
projet de l'eau ne soit même discuté
poser écrit ça illustre deux méthodes
différentes de communication politique
pour les faits est toujours le même
impact et l'opinion publique et donc
fédérer un plus grand nombre de français
autour de son projet parce que c'est ça
la bataille politique aussi et donc du
côté de la france insoumise et de la
nuque pour le moment on a décidé d'aller
dans les médias de faire de l'agit-prop
c'est une méthode qui a été voilà déjà
efficace ça cause ça existe depuis les
années 70 et puis du côté du
rassemblement national parce que il ya
l'histoire de rassemblement national on
a décidé d'utiliser l'assemblée pour se
normaliser et donc d'avoir un pouvoir
contestataires à l'intérieur de
l'hémicycle et c'est ce type de en tout
cas d'opposition qui va s'installer me
semble-t-il allmand au début du
quinquennat quelle est la plus efficace
chômage n'en sais rien il faudra ensuite
demandé l'avis des français parce que
finalement ce programme pourquoi j'en ai
j'ai un peu discuté pendant le passage
du sujet parce que ce programme de l efi
c'est un peu
la même rengaine que jean luc mélenchon
à matignon c'est à dire que on a envie
de leur dire vous n'êtes pas au
gouvernement vous n'êtes pas au pouvoir
donc s'assurer rien soit son âge chaque
fois de nous resservir un programme bien
de dire à l'antenne aussi ce qu'on dit
pendant les sujets
de discussion alors vous l'avez dit les
uns les autres c'est effectivement un
thème consensuel mais beaucoup de
propositions différentes en voici une
elle est signée marine le pen c'était en
sortant de son rendez vous avec la
première ministre la semaine dernière
quand elisabeth bornes recevait les
chefs de partis ou de ou de groupe à
l'assemblée on écoute marine le pen qui
rappelait à la première ministre que je
souhaitais évidemment la baisse des
taxes sur l'énergie le gaz l'électricité
le fioul et le carburant et qui
m'apparaissait qui était beaucoup plus
cohérent de le faire par l'intermédiaire
de la baisse de la tva que je le faire
par l'intermédiaire de chèques dont
mise en oeuvre me paraît mettre une
nouvelle fois à l'écart les classes
moyennes et me paraît d'application
complexe c'est vrai mais il appelle ce
qu'il ya comme un petit risque d' usine
à gaz
oui oui et puis on voit là moi j'ai vu
juste un décret qui est paru samedi pour
les pour aider les entreprises les plus
touchées les augmentations c'est vrai
qu'il faut quand même être très bien
réveillés et bien en forme pour
comprendre exactement tous les critères
d'éligibilité
mais la mesure que propose marine le pen
est là aussi ça comme inconvénient c'est
qu'elle est pas du tout ciblé donc c'est
pour tourner donc allez viens juste et
c'est vrai que ce que bercy est en train
d'essayer de faire dans les propositions
c'est de cibler davantage les gens qui
ont le plus besoin à la fois parce
qu'ils conduisent davantage et parce
qu'ils sont les plus modestes on peut
pas leur retirer ça mais simplement moi
je pointe quelque chose et vous l'avez
dit le harem c'est les plus constructifs
dans le parlement en tout cas dans leur
communication déjà ils ont il est crevé
pour l'instant ça va commencer
dans la communication c'est on sera
constructif on votera quand ça nous
paraître anormal et je pense qu'à terme
et d'ailleurs ça a déjà commencé un
petit peu a discuté ça peut poser un
problème à ce gouvernement et à cette
majorité relative comme une espèce de
collaboration d'ailleurs j'ai dit ce mot
je sais pas pourquoi mais il me vient
comme ça avec le rassemblement national
un peu trop marquée parce que si le
rassemblement national laisse voter des
lois ou participent à des lois ça
voudrait dire que finalement comme vous
le disiez emmanuel macron gouverne non
seulement beaucoup plus à droite que
sont en même temps on avait promis mais
même quelquefois va piocher à l'extrême
droite des voix et c'est ce qu'on a
commencé à voir dans l'entre-deux tours
des législatives il n'y avait pas de
consigne de vote et l'a récemment avec
des ministres et des députés qui disait
mais bien sûr si les votes des arènes
viennent vers nous on va pas les refuser
mais c'était plutôt un petit peu lancé
la perche de ce côté là alors dans ce
gouvernement band 2 laetitia un
personnage qui est très important aussi
sur cette question du pouvoir d'achat
alors c'est pas un nouveau venu vous
avez choisi de 2 sur lequel vous avez
choisi de faire un focus c'est
évidemment de bruno le maire oui parce
qu'avant tout les autres hier avant même
l'annoncé officielle de l'elysée il a
confirmé qu'ils restaient en poste
c'était sur la matinale de france inter
en écoute ministre de l'économie et des
finances ou devriez l'être encore ce
soir après le remaniement c'est pas un
scoop absolue que de dire cela ce matin
nous sommes est pas un scoop allez donc
vous restait effectivement et pas de
suspense insoutenable vous concernant en
tout cas les secrétaires d'état passé
vous vous restez bruno le maire oui
que vous dire d'autre n'aurait rien
c'est une première c'est soi-même qu'on
reste avant le saut fatal général de
l'elysée mais c'est un disciple bon ce
n'était pas le secrétaire général de
l'elysée cette fois c'était un
communiqué mais c'est vrai c'est une
première le communiqué est tombé trois
heures après cette interview façon de
marquer son pouvoir ou tout simplement
de répondre aux questions de la
journaliste
c'est une façon de se distinguer du
peloton quitte à froisser le château je
ne sais pas si emmanuel macron était au
courant mais en tout cas et manière dont
bruno le maire a décidé et a montré
qu'il voulait occuper une place dans le
gouvernement born 2 alors déjà il
voulait matignon quand même thomas ça
lui est passé sous le nez il a compris
que c'était une femme qui devait être à
matignon mais il veut jouer un rôle
pivot alors bien sûr les capitalistes
sur son rôle de second du commandant du
bateau pendant la crise comme idi la
seconde et emmanuel macron qui a mené ce
paquebot france pendant la crise du coc
vide et surtout il est un des ministres
on en parle est un instant qui sera sur
le devant de la scène puisque il est un
des ministres phare fondamental pour
cette loi sur le pouvoir d'achat et
préoccupation numéro un des français
hypothèse que j'aimais ici il va se
positionner bruno le maire comme un vice
premier ministre exactement comme
l'avait fait pierre bérégovoy avec edith
cresson mai pierre bérégovoy qui lui
aussi
espérer matignon après michel rocard et
qu'ils avaient lui aussi avait atterri
avait refilé exactement et de plus merci
ils avaient surveillé edith cresson d'un
oeil je vais vous dire il l'avait pas
quitté des yeux en embuscade d'ailleurs
il n'hésitait pas de façon publique 1 à
contrecarrer à contredire la première
ministre sur telle ou telle orientation
économique et après le court règne
d'edith cresson à matignon c'est lui
pierre bérégovoy qui avait pris le poste
alors bruno le maire bien sûr joue sa
partition là pour le second quinquennat
thomas évidemment dans le gouvernement
bornes deux peut-être trois peut-être
quatre nous verrons plus tard mais bien
sûr aussi pour 2027 il sait comme tout
ce qui lie à la succession d'emmanuel
macron qui est déjà ouverte à une série
de bezina ça ça ouvre un chapitre que
l'on va consacrer maintenant la question
du vote de confiance et de la légitimité
finalement de la première ministre
est-ce qu'elle secoue se pose d'autant
plus cette question qu elisabeth board a
décidé de ne pas solliciter la confiance
alors sur le terrain de la légitimité
c'est vrai que je pense qu'il faut déjà
coupé court à toute question de bien élu
mal élu voilà on est dans une démocratie
appartient au moment où les français à
voter c'est voilà un gouvernement et un
parlement est légitime ça c'est une
première évidence pour la question
ensuite du caractère j'ai envie de dire
tenez à bhl gerra gouvernable 2 de la
suite
on a connu sous la vème des premiers
ministres qui ont rompu la tradition de
la présentation de la confiance le
premier c'est georges pompidou en 1966
qui nous fait tout un cours de droit
constitutionnel en interprétant
l'article 49 de manière totalement anti
constitutionnelle en me disant eh bien
j'ai le choix je décide que j'opterai ou
non pour ce choix de la confiance depuis
la coutume s'est installée donc voilà
elle n'a à garder son choix c'est vrai
que numériquement on voit pas trop
comment elle aurait pu obtenir la
confiance dans ces circonstances dont
c'est un soin de sécurité puisque ça
renverse la charge de la preuve en
quelque sorte d'ailleurs pompidou en 67
à nouveau ne présente pas la confiance
est dit à françois mitterrand avec un
ton tout à fait goguenard mais j'attends
votre motion censure donc on inverse
complètement en disant si l'opposition
salies tant pis je tombe mais sinon je
gouverne par défaut c'est quand même
risqué parce que sous la vème république
à chaque fois qu'on a fait cela et bien
on a dans les cinq six mois dû
représenter la confiance soit par un 49
3 soit par de nouvelles déclarations de
politique générale et donc il est
toujours important pour un gouvernement
d'avoir sa base parlementaire il faut
dire dans tous les autres régimes
parlementaires sauf le régime français
le gouvernement émanent directement et
directement il le leader du parti
majoritaire donc ce problème ne se pose
pas ici en france continuer à gouverner
sans avoir aucune alliance autour de soi
de son parlement ça va être quand même
très complet la ln confiance relative à
l'aide qu'elle est relative relative
donc voilà ça il faut que ce soit donc
il faut voir comment elle va
ali avec moi c'est avec avec avec l air
et ils vont naviguer texte par lequel il
ya projet de finances oui comment on va
faire c'est vrai que solliciter la
confiance il y avait un double piège
qu'il soit de voir les oppositions se
coaliser même si elles disent le
contraire on n'est pas l'abri d'un
retournement ou alors d'être de passer
mais avec une abstention du
rassemblement national ce qui en terme
d'image n'était pas non plus idéal
mathieu super qu'est ce qu'on peut
attendre du discours de politique
générale d isabelle borne peut-être une
ligne politique qu'il nous échappe un
peu depuis quelques mois et vous allez
me dire ça il ya deux choses il ya deux
choses à clarifier ou en tout cas
affirmé une ligne politique est par
ailleurs une forme d'autorité malgré
tout de la première ministre qui à ce
stade quand même en réalité on manque
compte tenu des circonstances de sa
nomination et ensuite des deux mois de
flottement on fait beaucoup le parallèle
quand on parle en ce moment de majorité
parle de majorité relative et de et de
vote de la confiance avec la situation
de 1988 et olivier verrey hier lui même
en conférence de presse après le conseil
des ministres faisait le parallèle en
disant on va pas le faire mais
d'ailleurs c'est tout à fait normal de
ne pas le faire rocard bérégovoy et
c'est en 1988 effectivement même avec
cette majorité relative la situation
politique est radicalement différent
siens françois mitterrand est réélu
largement réélu avec 54% des voix il est
honteux il est très haut dans les
enquêtes d'opinion et donc sa légitimité
à lui n'être absolument pas en a mais
est mieux michel rocard à matignon est
la personnalité politique préférée des
français à ce moment là et c'est même
l'opinion qui en était à imposer sa
présence à matignon à françois
mitterrand qui n'en voulait pas
forcément donc on a deux têtes de
l'exécutif qui sont à l'époque
parfaitement légitime et on se pose le
débat aujourd'hui alors que précisément
elisabeth bornes le chercher son nom est
faible on a compris qu encore une fois
elle n'était pas le premier choix du
président de la république d'abord pour
matignon on a ensuite compris que les
choses flotter pendant quelques semaines
qu'on ne savait pas si elle serait là
quelques jours seulement après et puis
ensuite encore une fois il ya cette
question de la ligne politique
totalement confuse non pas parce qu
emmanuel macron n'a pas eu de programme
on demand almagro n'a pas présenté
programme aux français c'est faux il a
présenté un programme extrêmement
technique extrêmement précis avec une
conférence de presse interminable mais
avant le premier tour sa ligne politique
était de centre droit voire même de
droite mais après étude
vient de ça on vient du fait que il a
changé de programme dans l'entre-deux
tours et donc on est passé de la
retraite à 65 ans à la planification
écologique et on ne sait pas du coup ce
que madame bande va faire moi j'ai
l'impression qu'on on entre dans une
autre dimension parce qu'en effet il ya
eu beaucoup de déception emmanuel macron
n'a pas réussi à voir les équipes qui
voulaient gagner le maquereau elisabeth
bornes n'ont pas eu les coalitions
qu'ils estiment et peut-être
envisageable et d'un coup on est dedans
un possible de réhabiliter simplement on
arrive avec des gestionnaires c'est pas
un gouvernement c'est des gestionnaires
en fait de la france et je pense que
c'est à l'image d'elisabeth bornes qu'on
a dit très efficace technocrates ils
vont prendre les dossiers en fur et à
mesure ils vont prendre les projets de
loi en voyant qui peut éventuellement
les voter c'est plus dû en même temps
c'est ni queue ni tête c'est à dire que
ça va être sans ligne réellement cela
ligne elle sera très opportuniste ou
même ces mêmes flux de l'opportunisme
pascal et limite la en même temps on
pouvait se dire que c'était de
l'opportunisme politique intelligente là
c'est par défaut par défaut on va voir
qui est préservé a voté quoi repose la
question de la demie la droite le
programme les manuels ma belle n'a pas
été tout le temps à droite dans
l'entre-deux tours de la présidentielle
avec leurs maisons écologiques et l'eau
est beaucoup plus à gauche rimer à la
droite
mais pourtant on prend plus non mais
juste pour terminer moi je me suis dit
finalement mais c'est pas idiot la
france elle est en plein bouleversement
pourquoi pas finalement une équipe
n'était pas une équipe de choc et
d'action c'est une équipe peut être
pragmatique un peu à l'image de bruno le
maire qui a essuyé en effet la crise
coville qui a avancé au fur et à mesure
qu a mis en place ce quoi qu'il en coûte
peut-être que c'est une époque où la
france a besoin de ça de plus de calme
alors l'assemblée va être beaucoup plus
agitée avec d'autres propositions mais
pourquoi pas et de toute façon il n'y a
pas le choix puisqu'il n'y a pas ni les
personnalités nico des coalitions et pas
de ligne directrice parce que moi je
suis pas d'accord je trouve que la ligne
directrice est plutôt d'accord avec vous
thomas n'est pas du tout clair elle se
précise qu'en fonction de qui est prêt à
voter c'est tout ce qui est celle là
c'est la seule clarté je vois dans le
programme on revient à la première
victoire la première élection de
distribuer
je vous propose d'entendre la réaction
de bruno retailleau sur la composition
de ce gouvernement bornes numéro deux le
président du groupe l air au sénat
c'était ce matin sur ses news
et surtout ce remaniement le fait qu
emmanuel macron n'est plus attractif il
ya beaucoup de ministres pourtant une à
plus de 40 mais cet entre soi donc c'est
un dosage entre les différentes
formations de la majorité nous allons
être dans l'opposition texte par texte
bien sûr mais ce sera une opposition
d'intérêt général simplement ce
gouvernement encore une fois ce qui est
important désormais c'est la ligne c'est
le cas pendant cinq ans le en même temps
nous a privés de cap ça abîme et le pays
et maintenant vas falloir réformer enfin
je reviens pas sur le cas pour vient
d'en débattre mais sur l'attractivité
anne-charlotte bezina est ce que vous
êtes en partie d'accord avec bono otayo
est ce que finalement il n'y a pas eu ce
souci d'attractivité peut-être notamment
pour faire venir des personnalités de la
société civile et au combien de temps va
durer ce gouvernement board numéro 2
prendre des coups la haute autorité sur
la transparence dans les pubs bref on va
pas faire toute la liste mais est ce
qu'il ya un manque d'attractivité pour
trois choses la première c'est qu'il ya
un mauvais signe c'est le retour
d'anciens ministres
la formation 2010 est où là on a le
sentiment en effet qu'on va plutôt faire
confiance à des anciens donc c'est vrai
que le côté nouveauté est un peu en
berne deuxième chose il ya aussi l'idée
de recomposer sa majorité avec les
nuances de sa majorité et ça c'est pas
nouveau sous la vème république parce
que vous avez l'exemple de 67 par
exemple où la majorité gaulliste doit
vraiment se sentent risée pour essayer
de plongée des velléités de valéry
giscard d'estaing et où voilà on recrée
un peu une famille gaulliste centriste
etc et où finalement comme on sent que
la majorité est courte il faut arriver a
déjà joué ce qui est jouable c'est à
dire que toutes les nuances de ensemble
elles s'entendent juste mais la femme en
d'élargir sa majorité faut la consolider
exactement avant d'élargir sa majorité
il faut la consolider et puis le
troisième point c'est que l'absence
d'attractivité elle est un peu dans
l'air du temps en général il ya une
défiance envers la politique ce soit en
italie en allemagne en autriche et c'est
donc ça devient de moins en moins facile
d'entrer au gouvernement parce qu'il ya
beaucoup d'impératifs à remplir en plus
il ya les différentes exigences de la
majorité de l'ouverture à droite à
gauche la parité le caractère technique
de ce nouveau gouvernement et la
bataille parlementaire alors on aurait
pu jouer l'effet d'opinion ça c'est
vraiment quelque chose auquel on pouvait
s'attendre c'est à dire se dire bon bah
comme l'effet parlementaire d'ouverture
ne pourra pas exister au moins qu'au
niveau de l'opinion on est quelques
effets waouh comme on aime bien
maintenant je sais pas à vulgariser ce
propos des faits whaou et c'est vraiment
pas eu donc quelque chose de secure pour
la tempête moi parler de la motion de
censure tout de suite et j'appelle
quentin calme est à nous rejoindre
bonsoir cantat bienvenue la nuque a donc
décidé de lancer cette motion de censure
elle sera à voter à priori par tous les
députés de la coalition voilà c'est ça
il aura fallu à peu près 24 heures de
discussions au sein de ces quatre
groupes parlementaires qui a composent
la nuque la france insoumise avait
dégainé très tôt un désir en apprenant
qu elisabeth bornes ne se soumettrait
pas un vote de confiance mais thil
panneau avait twitté madame bornes on ne
maltraite pas la démocratie impunément
nous vous ferons donc venir de force
devant le parlement dès ce mercredi nous
déposerons une motion de censure contre
le gouvernement est donc cet après midi
ces députés de la nuque ont réuni la
presse salle des quatre colonnes à
l'assemblée nationale pour présenter
leur motion et insisté sur l'unité des
groupes écoutez mathieu palau nous nous
voulons réaffirmer le principe qui est
un principe démocratique de base qui est
celui que la première ministre doit
demander devant l'assemblée nationale un
vote de confiance et que donc nous ne
pouvons pas laisser passer le fait que
parce qu'elle n'a pas de majorité parce
qu'elle est en quelque sorte elle se
voilent les yeux sur le résultat de ces
élections législatives et du choix qui
ont été faits par le peuple français eh
bien elle refuse de demander cette
confiance donc ce n'est pas à lié même
je dirais même à 100 à son discours même
si évidemment beaucoup de choses à dire
sur cette question là mais c'est sur une
question de principe puisqu'elle nous
refuse le vote de confiance ou lui
faudrait pendante avec une motion de
défiance donc là nulle sera uni a priori
jusqu'au bout on se demander quelle
serait l'attitude de certains députés au
sein de cette coalition par exemple on
avait vu valérie rabault la nouvelle
présidente vice présidente socialiste de
l'assemblée nationale qui exprimait des
doutes c'était hier soir sur notre
antenne écoutez là une motion de censure
nous en débattrons demain lors de la
réunion du groupe socialiste et
apparentés effectivement si elle est pas
voter bas ça renforce dans le confort
douillet libre je dirai demain matin que
je n'y suis pas favorable lors de
marignan groupe simon groupe décide de
s'y associer je serai loyal dont vous la
vôtre et avec le groupe ps si toutefois
ils décidèrent à décider demain une
hausse finalement unis mais cette motion
de censure était une chance d'aller au
bout
non effectivement là l'émotion est
défini dans l'article 49 de la
constitution 49,2 pour rappel il faut
que 58 députés c'est-à-dire un dixième
des membres de l'asso nationale sint
ensemble une motion pour qu'elle soit
soumise au vote mais la marche est très
haute pour les opposants au gouvernement
pour ensuite la faire adopter pour
rappel la majorité absolue à la social
se situe à 2 189 députés c'est le nombre
de votants à atteindre pour barrer la
route à labé de bornes mais a priori la
nuque ne rassemble que 147 députés et
les autres groupes d'opposition ont déjà
annoncé qu'ils ne voteront pas la motion
de censure venu de la gauche ça a été
dit par exemple par annie genevard pour
les l air même chose pour le
rassemblement national sébastien chenu a
dit cela trentaine c'était ce matin
a dit dans une institution pour
commencer par tout cas c est vouloir
destituer un gouvernement parce que
remplacer madame bornes par quelqu'un
par madame bornes bis ça n'a aucun
intérêt donc on va prendre acte de ce
qu'elle raconte on va voir jusqu'où nous
on peut faire monter nos propositions
et c'est comme ça qu'on se définit une
opposition qui s'oppose mais qui
construit voilà la motion donc pour être
examiné dans les prochains jours elle
permettra aux députés de gauche de
réaliser une forme de coup politique
paradoxalement et si thomas elle
renforce également et il avait de berne
car elle démontre qu'une majorité
n'existe pas pour la démettre de ses
fonctions effectivement merci quant à
mathieu soupière les oppositions vont se
compter ça va servir à ça ça nous
lissons de compte et c'est tout le
paradoxe que vous pointiez c'est la
force de la principale force
d'opposition qui là en l'occurrence
situe ni au moins elle fait la
démonstration de son union et sur ces
questions tout à fait fondamental pour
rentrer dans le débat parlementaire la
principale force d'opposition va
apparaître comme affaibli puisque
précisément elle ne va pas réussir son
pari politique alors elle le sait dès le
départ c'est une question de posture
mais il est incontestable que pour
partie en tout cas elle rend un peu
service à elisabeth bornes parce qu'on
va parler de l'échec de la motion de
censure et la question et visa parce
qu'ils l'une des questions alors on a eu
la réponse avec sébastien chenu mais
elle va se poser plusieurs fois sur
certainement d'autres textes d'autres
motions le rn va-t-il voter avec elle
est fille est ce que ça arrivera une
fois c'est très étonnant quand même
d'entendre sébastien chenu ses propos
très constructif très très calme
tous sont à cette image c'est à dire
d'être dans la construction
collaboration de deux textes ou quoi
donc ça va être très intéressant et très
délicat il me semble pour la majorité
l'un c'est justement le rn s'extrait de
ça et comme vous le disiez il pourrait
il aurait pu voter contre enfin s'il y
avait eu un vote de confiance s'opposer
à ça mais là ils ne choisissent pas de
se mettre à côté de lannux bien au
contraire on reste que dans une
opposition beaucoup plus raisonnables
raisonnée moi je trouve que c'est
intéressant quand même à noter parce que
beaucoup pensaient que la nuque ça
allait être terminée à peine les
élections législatives terminé que
c'était vraiment éphémère juste pour
marquer le coup on voit quand même
qu'ils ont réussi à proposer une
candidature commune pour la commission
des finances réussi jusqu'à quand on
s'est parlé avec eric coquerel avec ses
petits soucis d'accusation à voir s'il
reste là mais en tout cas ils ont réussi
cet exploit là ils réussissent là
attirés groupé pour cette deuxième fois
on peut dire que ça commence à
représenter quelque chose moi je suis
pas si sûr alors oui peut-être cela
conforterait elisabeth ce born parce que
cette motion de censure elle et c'est
sûr qu'elle ne passera pas mais quelque
part ça les positionne quand même et ça
leur permet encore une fois de proposer
leur projet de société c'est le seul qui
ait véritablement différent par rapport
à ce que propose emmanuel macron les
républicains un peu amendé et le
rassemblement national sur d'autres
aspects oui mais pas sur globalement la
ligne donc quelque part ça leur permet
quand même de proposer un projet de
société et de communiquer énormément
dessus et encore une fois les images
sont importantes de voir matt hill de
panneaux avec tout le monde autour même
les plus rétifs comme barreaux c'est
quand même marqué des points sur une
espèce d'opposition groupe et qui
s'organise alors vous parliez notamment
des questions et des dossiers de
d'accusation d'agression sexuelle on va
ouvrir un dernier chapitre dans dans ce
débat sur la sq il me semble intéressant
c'est comment les partis politiques
peuvent gérer ou pas ses dossiers en
interne pourquoi je vous dis ça parce
que il ya ces accusations qui ont été
lancées aujourd'hui par tabou ap ce
début mais je vous le rappelle après des
accusations d'agression sexuelle il a
retiré sa candidature l'islate yves en
justifiant son renoncement par les
attaques racistes dont il faisait
l'objet il charge aujourd'hui la france
insoumise et clémentine autain dans un
long texte dans lequel ils demandent la
clarification et la vérité je vais le
site et je me suis tenu silencieux pour
ne pas nuire à la campagne de l'union de
la gauche car il y avait urgence à
priver la macro ni d'une majorité
absolue maintenant c'est l'heure de la
clarification et de la vérité tabou
affirme que clémentine autain lui a
demandé d'invoquer les attaques racistes
et de retirer sa candidature il raconte
également et c'est là que je trouve ça
vraiment intéressant que lé fine lui a
pas permis de se défendre je le cite de
nouveau que dire d'une procédure qui ne
pose aucune question ne perd aucune
vérification ne donne aucune possibilité
de se défendre pire qui ne permet même
pas à la personne accusée de connaître
les faits qu'on lui reproche c'est la
version de taabo as pour l'instant elle
est fille jean luc mélenchon ou
clémentine autain n'ont pas réagi
laetitia c'est la question que j'ai
envie de vous poser une fois ce tweet
parce que c'est comme ça que tu as abu
hafs communique
par tweet c'est sur twitter aussi qu'il
s'est fait connaître une fois ce tweet
posté quelle sera la conséquence est ce
que elle est fille va réagir est ce que
l fille je trouve qu'en fait le procédé
est un peu étrange c'est à dire qu'on
prend à témoin l'opinion publique la
communauté de twitter certes mais après
comme les médias relais tout l'opinion
publique est prise à témoin est-ce que
par effet de ricochet est ce que la
pression sera telle que la france a
soumises
break et pas de réaction de l efi moi je
voudrais orienter le pardon c'est
intéressant bien qu'elle ait débat sur
la question des procédures internes je
commençais avec vous et me disent ah
parce qu'ils passent que dénonce la
bouillasse encore une fois on n'a pas la
version des les filles peut-être lui
dire que ça s'est passé autrement mais
lui dit face à des accusations
finalement je ne sais même pas de quoi
accuser est-ce que c'est aux partis
politiques ou même de gérer ses affaires
ou est-ce qu'il faut pas
systématiquement saisir la justice point
barre et moi j'ai eu il ya quelque chose
que je comprends pas en effet parce que
si ce qu'il dit est vrai il est accusé
il sait pas de quoi a priori les faits
sont assez graves mais la justice n'est
pas du tout dans le coup donc il ya oui
à des interrogations on a l'impression
qu'on est reparti dans des temps des
choses c'est de l'ordre du soviétisme
quoi ou c'est complètement noir et on
sort que ce qu'on veut sortir qui nous
intéresse ou qui nous arrange moi je
pense qu'il ya un vrai problème alors
que ça soit elle est fille en interne ou
autre il ya un vrai problème de
traitement de ces questions là je
comprends pas en entreprise on arrive à
traiter ya des guides il ya des
procédures on écarte les gens ont fait
des enquêtes internes mais au moins il
ya de la communication via de
l'information il ya un espèce de process
global pourquoi en politique on n'y
arrive pas je trouve que c'est très
déstabilisant c'est pas la première fois
qu'on a des cas alors là c'est un cas où
il est accusé il a pas il a pas de
réponse la plupart du temps c'est vous
êtes accusés mais il se passe rien on
nomme des ministres accusés de viol et
on s'en fiche on attend juste le dernier
remaniement pour les retirer je trouve
qu'il ya un véritable problème est qu'on
devrait se poser la question mais pas
forcément que les filles pas forcément
qu emmanuel macron et son gouvernement
qui était bancal à cause de ça et qu'il
est d'ailleurs toujours un peu pour
l'autre sur d'autres personnalités on
devrait se poser la question de savoir
si on peut pas régler les choses au
niveau politique parce que ça peut pas
durer comme ça revienne business school
dans une espèce de no man's land
juridique pour lui oui bien sûr il ya
plusieurs points d'abord la question des
investitures ya évidemment toujours une
commission d'investiture au sein d'un
parti pour choisir qui représentera dans
les circonscriptions ça c'est tout à
fait légitime et évidemment qu'il faut
que ça existe puisque c'est du ressort
vraiment de la compétence du parti et
c'est notamment à ce stade-là que la
candidature a bloqué sur le deuxième
point à la question de savoir s'il faut
traiter les violences sexistes et
sexuelles au sein d'organismes interne
comme la craie et elle est fille ma
réponse de jury sera évidemment en
négatif parce que je pense que on ne
peut pas organiser nécessairement de pré
filtre à juridictionnelle alors vous
voyez un parallèle avec les entreprises
que l'on fait pour
les femmes jusqu'à la haute autorité de
la transparence est vraiment juste une
autorité administrative indépendante qui
vérifie ou des conditions qui ont été
posées par la loi alors encore
faudrait-il que la loi saisisse de la
question c'est encore autre chose et du
coup ça vaudrait pour tous les partis
politiques et on serait dans un principe
d'égalité ici l'idée que un organisme
interne s'auto décrète
récepteurs de la parole des femmes
n'étant composé que de femmes dans des
conditions qui ne sont ni clarifier dans
le statut need actualisé nulle part moi
me pose franchement un problème
notamment parce que troisième point on
se défend uniquement sur le terrain
médiatique et c'est la question du média
que vous posiez mais parce que l'attaqué
médiatique la réponse est donc
médiatique donc le court-circuitage se
fait au niveau de la justice et c'est
dangereux pour la présomption
d'innocence pour les droits de la
défense pour la valeur de la parole des
femmes et pour la manière dont on aura
de ce traité ce sujet dans l'avenir
c'est ce que je voulais terminer là
dessus j'ai ou de la parole mathieu
croire la parole des femmes c'est
évidemment le principe de base surtout
quand elles sont plusieurs a raconté des
faits similaires il ya d'autres dossiers
médiatiques notamment qui montre sa des
modes opératoires qui se répète mais il
faut être quand même un peu lucide
mathieu st pierre c'est aussi une arme
politique et ses dossiers peuvent
devenir des armes politiques on peut pas
les analyser mais faisant abstraction de
cette dimension là pour le coup et c'est
tout le problème parce que une traite
d'un sujet qui là encore précisément et
hautement consensuel personnes en fait
monsieur tout le monde et pour la
libération de la parole des femmes
j'aurais à quelques exceptions près
comme m et on est tous d'accord pour se
dire il faut que collectivement on
s'organise pour pouvoir traiter le mieux
possible en fait ces cas qui sont des
cas émergents on sait qu'avant encore
une fois le couvercle était imposé sur
la cocotte et donc ça n'existait pas et
aujourd'hui on est absolument la cocotte
déborde et c'est ça la difficulté je
trouve pas en fait qui est de grande
confusion autour de cette affaire
d'abord encore une fois un parti
politique une organisation est fondé à
avoir ce type d'instance con comme
aujourd'hui on demande à un certain
nombre d'entreprises d'assumer un
certain nombre de responsabilités de
mettre en place des cellules d'écouté
etc personne ne trouve ça anormal et
personne d'ailleurs ne demande à ses
instances de se substituer à la justice
s'est passé voilà c'est juste une
instance de régulation interne mais ça
permet donner ce sentiment mais mais en
l'occurrence et cias a encore une fois
adulte où tous ceux qui sont salariés
d'une entreprise qui peut être confronté
à des faits de harcèlement qu'il soit
moral ou sexuel peuvent tout à fait être
confronté à ce type d'instance dans une
entreprise parce qu'une entreprise
aujourd'hui considéré comme ayant une
responsabilité sur le sujet
indépendamment de ce que la justice peut
par ailleurs faire les derniers éléments
sur cette affaire il n'y a pas de
confusion depuis le départ évidemment sa
flotte un peu pour une raison simple que
clémentine autain a rappelé dès le
départ là où les plaignantes ont fait
valoir un certain nombre de faits tout
en demandant l'absolu l'intégrale
confidentialité autour du sujet et donc
en réalité la france insoumise à demain
non non non je crois qu'il ya un sens
parce que quelque part on lui a demandé
en fin officiellement on a déclaré que
c'était parce qu' il n'était pas
agresser mais parce que sur les quelque
6 sacrés quand même beaucoup beaucoup de
confusion il n'entretenait pas de lui
même
le départ encore une fois les
plaignantes ont demandé à ce que cette
affaire
pour ça pour le faire partir et dire ça
décrédibilise complètement à la parole
des femmes je suis désolé et non à
partir du moment où les îles ayant elle
même demande à ce que cette affaire ne
soit pas posé sur la place publique
comment faites vous je ne dis pas du
tout la france a soumise à adopter la
bonne position mais comprenons
collectivement en fait la difficulté la
sensibilité du sujet et la difficulté
dès lors que laly meignan tel même
refuse que ce soit sur la place publique
c'est sûr que ça signifie endroit qu'on
installe un principe de prévention qui
en soi peut se défendre c'est à dire à
partir du moment où quelque chose n'est
et bien c'est trop tard ont désinvesti
la personne mais moi je trouve qu'il ya
quand même un contentieux avec les
droits de la défense parce que
précisément si on garde la
confidentialité mais qu'on garde la
sanction avec du coup il ya quand même
un problème pour l'osm pas
les choses à travailler là dessus en
tout cas le consensus est réelle il
avait raison et c'est très intéressant
il ouvre un débat peut-être qu'on refera
dans cette émission parce qu'on n'a pas
fini et heureusement que la parole se
libère de de l'évoquer notamment pour la
politique merci à tous encore une fois
d'avoir participé à ce débat mathieu je
rappelle le titre de votre livre coécrit
avec damien fleurot 2022 la flambée
populiste publié aux éditions plon